[Musique]
pierre-jean chalencon évoque la
perquisition qui a eu lieu hier après
midi chez lui au palais vivienne
location
pour sa peine et je vais combien
kefi votre nom n'est pas sorti camille
lellouche sont pas encore dans un
vestiaire comme quoi dire je fais moi ça
me fait pas râler les restaurants
clandestins souvent dans la main moi ce
qui me fait râler c'est ce qu'ils sont
pas ouverts une perquisition avait déjà
eu lieu au domicile parisien du
cuisinier christophe leroy cette fois il
est soupçonné d'avoir organisé de luxure
repas clandestins au palais vivienne
notamment son avocat estime qu'il n'a
rien fait d'illégal serpent lieu
uniquement dans des domiciles privés
on ne peut pas réglementer ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur d'un domicile privé
s'est expressément prévus par le conseil
constitutionnel
la police est intervenue hier soir dans
un restaurant clandestins à paris plus
de 110 personnes ont été verbalisées
pour avoir enfreint les règles en
vigueur en pleine crise sanitaire selon
la préfecture de police
l'organisateur et le gérant ont été
interpellés par hasard j'étais sur un
autre sujet de reportage et lorsque et
bien je m'approche d'un restaurant juste
à côté du périphérique à une centaine de
mètres du périphérique porte de
saint-ouen et bien je repère un manège
d'abord de plusieurs personnes qui
arrivent plutôt bien habillés des hommes
qui sont déposés en taxi en moto taxi
avec des berlines de luxe et 4 4 qui
s'arrêtent devant un restaurant
c'est impossible
j'arrive d'abord dans ses cuisines où
vous voyez il ya encore des frites qui
sont à peine sorti de l'huile la viande
qui est posée prête à être à être servi
à tous ses clients des assiettes qui
sont déjà dressées une serveuse qui est
là un petit peu désemparé et puis tous
ses clients qui sont là derrière au fond
de l'image est bien à table et alors là
il avait le masque parce que les
policiers leur ont demandé de mettre le
masque
mais lorsque je déambule à l'intérieur
du restaurant est bien ce que je vois ce
sont environ 60 personnes attablées sans
aucune distanciation sociale l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur brice hortefeux
a reconnu avoir participé à un repas
dans un appartement en présence de
l'éditorialiste alain duhamel
le député républicain évoque un déjeuner
professionnel et non pas un déjeuner
clandestins il a rappelé les gestes
barrières ont selon lui été respectée on
va y aller très gentil mais c'est vrai
que depuis quelques temps ils laissent
personne touchée awards font parce que
pour lui il ya que lui qui peut ramener
les poissons ont fait passer un petit
peu des fois pour des déserts et des des
taux bas
je n'ai pas la télé déjà ya 20 ans était
pratiquement jamais pensé que vous avez
cassé après le loft n'ont jamais trouvé
la télévision mais c'est vrai que ces
genres de programmes moi qui me fait
peur à est ce que j'avance que ça rend
les gens un peu bête mais non regardez
regardez ce pays c'est devenu si
intelligent depuis un singe je joue aux
jeux vidéo bong seulement avec la pensée
cette vidéo impressionnante a été
diffusé cette nuit par nora link elle la
société d'elon musk qui développe des
puces implantées dans le cerveau
pour parvenir à ce résultat le macaque
de 9 ans a appris à jouer à l'aide d'un
joystick et d'un smoothie à la banane
qu'il ingurgite à travers une paille
la puce électronique enregistre
l'activité cérébrale et une fois la
manette enlever la partie continue steve
jobs ou les les autres patrons de la
silicon valley oubliettes
toutes ces familles là ont des enfants à
qui ils interdisent ça m'a fait marrer
les tablettes l'utilisation du téléphone
portable à table où ils vont même dans
des écoles où il n'ya pas d'ordinateur
parce que c'est mieux qu'ils apprennent
avec des vrais livres du vrai papier et
des vrais stylo et vous dites c'est un
peu comme des dealers de cocaïne qui en
gros vous ventes de nokia cocaïne mais
on n'en prennent pas fait être des gens
ou en écoute ce qu'ils disent quoi moi
j'adore les mots et ces dons seront tu
aimes les mots mais l'appartement se
fout pardon goethe interrogeant devient
fou bien fou le mec vraiment on est là
on est quoi on est là on enchaîne des
pas alors c'est pas à nous de parler on
est filmé on ne sait même plus comment
s'est donc dit don mello est-ce qu'ils
avaient des exigences ses stars quand
elle quand vous êtes mariah carey ou
jennifer lopez jennifer lopez il fallait
que tout soit blanc dans la loge je suis
pas très pratique mais bon je m'inquiète
blanche meubles blancs
voilà il y avait aussi eu bat maria
carey je sais que trois femmes mariah
carey venu il fallait des toilettes
privées qu'elle fait qu'elle fait nagui
de pouvoir faire des émissions comme la
tienne parce que quand on s'est
retrouvés et toi pour répéter aurait
répétition ça dit répété mais là s'est
pas répétée c'est tout nouveau vont se
retrouve on se tombe dans les bras
cpt quoi en fait c'est directement
retire l'europe et ça fait sa fête de
joie
et là on tournait avec des toilettes
pour tout le monde mais paraît que
révéler son secret du coup on a pris les
toilettes pour tout le monde on écrit
mariah carey dessus et tout le temps ils
pouvaient ce l'avé maria qu'elle est
l'inconvénient d'avoir un prénom en
guise de nom pas de se faire confondre
très souvent des captures en série emile
louis
très embêtant est-ce que j'ai passé une
bonne semaine fait écouter comme ça
avoue n'est meilleur que le prince
philip au nom de faucher a à peine 99
ans et c'est tellement injuste
le prince philip duc d'edimbourg vient
de s'éteindre à l'âge de 99 ans
l'information historique est également
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux
officiel de la monarchie
toute la journée les hommages des
britanniques se sont multipliés philippe
c'est lui que l'on voit ici à côté de sa
majesté elizabeth 2 il s'était mariée en
1947 des années des décennies d'un
mariage qu'on disait très heureux
personnalité extrêmement populaire au
royaume uni a entendu des anglais
désigner les français sous le nom de
grenouilles
mais j'ai abstiendrai de répéter les
termes employés par les français pour
faire allusion aux embiez si un anglais
est extrêmement poli avec vous c'est qui
vous détestent si un anglais et un juste
sympa agréable ne fait pas trop
d'efforts il vous aime bien l'anglais
vous charrie vous sort des femmes et qui
c'est qui vous adore et s'il vous dit
qu'ils vous aiment pas franchement c'est
pas un anglais on est plus souvent duper
par la défiance que par la confiance
autrement dit aimez vous les uns les
autres sans pour autant insérer vos
doigts non pour tous